[Music]
its audience is incredibly nice I have
to say my god I'm not always on TV
haven't been around a while so it just
warms my heart cuz I'm one of those
quiet I'm like a junior celebrity I can
hide in public you know because like
you're 6 9 yes 9 with red hair you can't
go anywhere but with me if I put some
glasses on and a hat I'm invisible the
only way they can take me is the mouth
and so it's not a joke I actually do the
Jay Leno mouth to make myself completely
invisible so I'm like this and I walk
around like take this away sorry to
bring up Jay
no no they weren't booing you now that
moments gonna go viral I'm curious about
something we don't show there a long
time and I'm starting out live used to
bring your kids by and they were they
were they were they were like little
tykes cute little boys and now they're
you know eighteen and twenty it's funny
when you're Captain know as a parent
like your kids come up with plans and
you just have to listen to the plan so
the plan would this is what I'm hearing
stuff like dad we're gonna drive to Lake
Tahoe tonight
we're gonna leave at 1:00 in the morning
and we're gonna drive all night well
who's driving wouldn't this guy named
Philippe he's a substitute teacher and
Drake and we're gonna drive all night
and snowboard for an hour and then drive
back I'm gonna have to say no never said
the F word this much on a joke
you saved it for us now I can't stop
can't stop we're gonna take a train to
Guadalajara and do you have a passport
money we're gonna stay doesn't matter
dad don't worry chill
just relax but what is your problem dad
so many no matter what they say you put
the brakes on it
anyway and you're the bad guy yeah your
captain no captain no no no no and then
the latest thing they do is you should
be happy if anything goes wrong you
should be happy dad because you got a D
in math you guys you should be happy I
know a kid who flunked every class you
ever took you should be happy I know a
guy who steals cars you should be so
happy dad and people ask me do they
really talk like that yeah pretty much
yeah it's kind of that little change
sort of voice that they do you know they
must love when you talk a little bit
like guard
[Applause]